[Music]
how could you be so Heartland we're
calling this the one where Courtney Cox
pokes fun at Kanye West how did that
happen well it all happened because of
the rapper's recent Instagram post just
just do something for my heart which
read I actually didn't write the tweet
that said friends wasn't funny either
but I wish I had a reference to this
viral screen grab apparently faked by
fans which surfaced after Court's
friend's co-star Jennifer Aniston posted
that it wasn't funny to vote for Kanye
in the 2020 election steady as a rock
now are you with me
all right let's do it come on okay so
Court AKA Monica shared this video
jamming out to Kanye's song heartless
before noticing his message
[Music]
Courtney's caption I bet the old Kanye
thought friends was funny I missed the
old Kanye now Court's no stranger to
keeping friends Alive and Well on social
media I just remember it being such an
amazing time back in April she tested
out a filter that's supposed to turn you
into the cast hi
really I don't even look anything like
sure Joey how you doing oh looks good
with an earring or two and let's just
say she had a little difficulty figuring
out if the face is Monica's or Rachel's
oh hello who was that
was that Monica not sure
Rachel
I have no idea this is one of the worst
apps I've ever seen but okay is that me
no I think my eyebrows are a little
different
uh Rachel
I don't buy it it's the worst mouth of
anyone so it's not Jennifer or Rachel
because she's got a gorgeous mouth and
I've this is me yeah we'll stick with
the real deal and sorry Kanye but
friends it was funny hey do you realize
that at one time or another we all lived
in this apartment
oh yeah that's true uh I haven't
looked such great writers the whole
thing was the best experience that I
could possibly imagine I felt very lucky
to have been a part of that show and
everything kind of seems to pale in
comparison whenever I read comedies I'm
just like Ugh can't compare because we
were really lucky and that our
just the friendships the chemistry
like I said writers The Producers the
whole thing
[Music]